[Music]
Valentina mila kunis are back in putting
a holiday spin on the sequel of bat
bombs Christmas Brooke Anderson hit the
set to hang with Mila we finished the
first one and this movie's gonna come
out almost a year to the date and within
that year I have a baby there you go and
look at her I mean we never know when in
Evernote lots of jimang okay this is
looks like what do you mean this is all
natural
whose struggle is real for Mama Mila and
the mom of two is a shy about telling it
like it is
what is different for you this time
around with too much conds I think I'm a
little bit less stressed over what to
anticipate yeah and I was pretty relaxed
at the first and so the second one's
really fully I mean it's one of those
I'm like where is he
that doesn't make her a bad mom right
but in this sequel to last year's hit
well Mila Kristen Bell and Kathryn Hahn
are still overworked and
underappreciated but now they have to
deal with their own mom she's the most
critical human being on the planet I
can't fix that beyonce some phenomenal
cast additions this time around
christine baranski Susan Sarandon Cheryl
Hines and Mila and the others basically
handpicked them I cannot wait to spin
every waking minute with you Oh No
I've known Cheryl for over 10 years and
I adore her no more gifts no more
perfect decorations don't what perfect
anything and given the holiday theme of
the movie we couldn't help but ask Mila
about her perfect Christmas traditions
with Ashton and the kids so far our
tradition is no presents for the kids oh
really yes I love we're instituting it
this year we'd like to take a charitable
donation like to like the Children's
Hospital or to whatever you want now
Mila says that deal with the presence
works because their kids are spoiled by
their grandparents all but just wait
meal until they get a little bit older
and their friends start tell them about
their gifts
[Music]
you